lay misera like the Oscar winning roll
and I know I botch that how do you say
it I I frequently don't I don't talk
about l l Oscar winning roll was it your
idea to cut your hair on screen yes it
was yes it was it that was my idea
because that's a bold and intimate
Choice it was it was it was a very bold
and a very intimate Choice um the reason
we did it was because I went to Tom
Hooper the director and I said listen
we're actors singing live in a movie and
I think you know I I don't know I'm just
audiences aren't used to that and I
think we need to make it real for them
we need to show them that we all left
that pound of Flesh on on uh the floor
basically so anyway he went away thought
about it and then was like Annie you
know what you're right we're going to do
it and I was like oh my God oh my God
and I ran out into I I got the call and
I was in the bedroom and I ran out in
the living room like Adam Adam oh my God
honey guess what I'm I'm they're gonna
let me shave my head they're gonna let
me do it and he was like oh great and I
was like I was like what and he's like
no no it's it's just it's so it's such a
you know I support the choice and and
it's going to be amazing there's just I
didn't want I don't know how there's
just one thing you haven't thought of
I'm like what he's like we're just
getting married a couple months later
and I was like
oh but I'm still going to do it
[Music]
yeah